Everybody's gone!
Honey, this summer
is gonna be great.
You're going to make friends.
There's nothing
to worry about.
Welcome to
the Rim of the World
AdventureCamp.
Alex, I am your leader, Logan.
-I love you.
-Mom!
Zhenzhen!
Where are you going?
I don't think we should
wander this far.
Maybe we should head back?
Follow me.
What was that?
Never seen
anything like them.
It's Independence Day.
It's June, Gabriel!
We need to wait here until
the adults realize they left us.
Go! Run!
Did you see
the size of that thing?
Stop talking.
Please stop.
Was that an alien?
Let's go!
It has the dog!
We need to find our parents.
We got to get to the city.
Do not move!
We're at war.
You're not safe here.
-You'd better go.
-We can't leave you!
Take this key.
It's on you now.
This is a cryptokey.
It can activate
our satellite defense.
We should try to find JPL.
It's a NASA facility
70 miles away from here.
How are we supposed to go
70 miles?
1973 Ford Mustang Mach 1.
I can't drive a stick.
-Yeah, Zhenzhen!
-Hold on tight!
This is Animal Kingdomhere.
-Hang on!
-We have each other.
And we can't give up now.
I'm your master now.
No, the line is,
"Now I am the master."
Okay, we really need
to get you a girl.
May I propose a toast?
Crap! This is from 1969.
At least get fresh wine
if this is gonna be
my first time, right?